>> Laura: IT'S FRIDAY.
YOU KNOW IT IS.
THAT MEANS IT'S TIME FOR FRIDAY
FOLLIES.
CHRIS CUOMO PHONES HOME AND SOME
MOW
MVIE REBOOTS GO DOWN IN PHRASE.
HERE'S RAYMOND ARROYO.
YOU HAVE BREAKING BIDEN NEWS?
>> HIS SON, HUNTER, WAS SUED IN
AUGUST BY A WOMAN THAT CLAIMS
SHE HAD A RELATIONSHIP AND A
CHILD WITH BIDEN'S SON.
SHE WAS A STUDENT AT GEORGE
WASHINGTON UNIVERSITY WHEN THEY
MET.
HUNTER DENIED THE RELATIONSHIP
AND PATERNITY.
THE RESULTS OF A COURT-MANDATED
DNA TEST ARE IN.
FOR THIS, WE GO TO OUR SPECIAL
FIELD CORRESPONDENT.
>> YOU ARE THE FATHER!
>> EVERY CHILD IS A BLESSING,
LAURA.
JOE BIDEN DIDN'T SEEM TO PLEASED
WHEN PETER DOOCY ASKED HIM ABOUT
HIS NEW GRANDCHILD.
>> WONDERING IF YOU HAVE A
COMMENT OUT OF ARKANSAS THAT
YOUR SON, HUNTER, JUST MADE YOU
A GRANDFATHER AGAIN?
>> NO.
THAT'S A PRIVATE MATTER.
NO COMMENT.
ONLY YOU WOULD ASK THAT.
YOU'RE A GOOD MAN.
CLASSY.
>> CLASSY?
IF I WERE JOE BIDEN I WOULDN'T
BE THROWING CLASSY AROUND WHEN
HUNTER -- I LOVE THAT.
HE DENIED THE RELATIONSHIP AND
EVER MEETING HER.
SO NOW --
>> NOT ONLY DID HE MEET HER, HE
HAD A CHILD WITH HER.
>> Laura: IF YOU CAN'T TRUST HIM
ON HIS OWN FLESH AND BLOOD, HOW
DO YOU TRUST HIM ON I DIDN'T
SPEAK TO MY DAD AT ALL ABOUT
BURISMA?
>> THE BIDENS HAVE BEEN TRASHING
TRUMP NOR BEING A REALITY STORE.
LOOKS LIKE THEY'RE DOING IT.
DURING THE IMPEACHMENT HEARINGS,
DAVID HOLMES THAT WORKED AT THE
U.S. UKRAINIAN EMBASSY TESTIFIED
THAT HE OVERHEARD A CONVERSATION
BETWEEN THE PRESIDENT AND
AMBASSADOR SONDLAND.
HE CLAIMS HE COULD HEAR THE
PRESIDENT'S VOICE DESPITE THE
FACT THAT THE CALL WAS NOT ON
SPEAKER PHONE.
THE PRESIDENT SAID MY HEARING IS
ALWAYS GREAT.
NEVER HAVE I SEEN A PERSON
MAKING A CALL THAT WAS NOT ON
SPEAKER PHONE AND BE ABLE TO
HEAR OR UNDERSTAND A
CONVERSATION.
I TRIED IT TO NO AVAIL.
TRY IT LIVE.
SO CNN'S CHRIS CUOMO TRIED IT
LIVE WITH HIS MOMMA.
>> VERY INTERESTING THEORY FROM
OUR PRESIDENT.
HE'S NEVER BEEN ABLE TO HEAR A
PHONE CALL WHEN IT WASN'T ON
SPEAKER PHONE FROM ANYBODY.
SO LET'S JUST PLAY WITH THAT FOR
A SECOND.
MOM, CAN YOU HEAR ME?
I'M WITH DANA.
DID SHE JUST SAID HELLO?
MOM?
I CAN'T HEAR YOUR MOTHER.
>> THIS IS ACROSS THE TABLE.
>> HE COULDN'T GET CONFIRMATION.
IF YOU'RE GOING TO PULL A STUNT
LIKE THIS, TEST IT OUT FIRST AND
MAKE SURE EVERYBODY CAN HEAR.
BY THE WAY, HE HAD HIS PHONE ON
SPEAKER.
THAT IS NOT WHAT THE PRESIDENT
SAID.
SO IT'S -- THIS WAS A DISASTER
FOR CHRIS CUOMO.
>> Laura: I KEEP THINKING THE
GLOVE WITH O.J. AND DIDN'T FIT.
KIND OF LIKE THAT.
>> MARSHA CLARK.
>> Laura: OH, WAIT A SECOND.
>> MRS. CUOMO IS LIKE WHEN
THEY'RE LISTENING ON THE RADIO.
>> Laura: BUT IT'S HARD TO HEAR
IT.
>> IT IS.
YOU'RE NOT LISTENING TO THE
PHONE.
>> Laura: AND I LIKE WHEN MOMS
AND DADS COME ON SHOWS.
MINE ARE NO LONGER WITH US.
BUT AT SOME POINT IT DOES BECOME
A LITTLE -- HE COULD HAVE DONE
THE SAME THING WITH DANA OR HAD
A PRODUCER CALL IN.
THIS IS A LITTLE LIKE DAYTIME
TV.
>> CUOMO MIGHT CONSIDER A SECOND
CAREER AS A PRODUCT
DEMONSTRATOR.
ELON MUSK AT TESLA MIGHT HAVE A
JOB FOR HIM.
MUSK UNVEILED THE NEW CYBER
TRUCK.
IT'S ARMORED WINDOWS AND WALLS
ARE BULLETPROOF MUSK INSISTED.
GO AHEAD.
THROW SOMETHING AT IT.
>> OH, MY [BLEEP].
MAYBE THAT WAS A LITTLE TOO
HARD.
[LAUGHTER]
>> TRY THE OTHER ONE.
REALLY?
>> OH, MAN.
>> DIDN'T GO THROUGH.
>> HE SAID THEY'RE GOING TO FIX
IT AND POST.
>> Laura: THIS IS ANOTHER THING,
ANOTHER EXPERIMENT IN REAL TIME
THAT YOU HAVEN'T PRODUCT TESTED
BEFORE.
>> YOU HAVE TO REHEARSE THESE
THINGS.
THIS GUY, BY THE WAY, MUSK LOST
$720 MILLION AS A RESULT OF
THAT.
>> Laura: DROP IN THE BUCKET.
DIDN'T THE KARDSHIAN DAUGHTER
MAKE $600 MILLION OR SELLING
THAT IN HER MAKEUP COMPANY?
SHE'S 22.
ALL RIGHT.
THERE'S BEEN A STRING OF
FLAME-OUTS AT THE BOX OFFICE IN
RECENT WEEKS.
THEY ALL SEEM TO INVOLVE
REBOOTS.
NOW, WHAT IS GOING ON?
THIS HAS BEEN HAPPENING FOR SOME
TIME.
IT ONLY PICKED UP STEAM IN HOW
BAD THEY'RE FLAILING.
>> THE AUDIENCE MAY BE TIRING OF
THESE ENDLESS REMAKES AND
REBOOTS.
ELIZABETH BANKS SECOND CHARLIE
ANGELS REBOOT WITH KRISTIN
STEWART COST $50 MILLION TO
PRODUCE.
IT HAD AN OPENING WEEKEND OF $21
MILLION.
A FLOP.
PART OF THE REASON IS THIS WAS
AWOKE FEMINIST CHARLIE'S ANGELS.
YOU REMEMBER THE ORIGINAL.
IT WAS A SHOW THAT GUYS COULD
WATCH.
ACTION, BEAUTY.
THIS NEW ITERATION WAS
DIFFERENT.
>> WOMEN CAN DO ANYTHING.
>> JUST BECAUSE THEY CAN DOESN'T
MEAN THEY SHOULD.
>> WE'VE HEARD THAT SO MANY
TIMES.
>> DIRECTOR ELIZABETH BANKS
EXPLAINED HER VISION FOR THE
REBOOT THIS WAY.
>> I WAS IN LOVE WITH THE IDEA
OF WATCHING THESE PROFESSIONAL
WOMEN AT THEIR JOB.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT THE BOYFRIEND
THAT THEY DON'T SEE ENOUGH, THE
DOG THEY'RE NOT FEEDING, THE MOM
THEY'RE NOT CALLING.
>> LAURA, AUDIENCES DON'T WANT
TO BE TALKED DOWN TO OR MEN
ATTACKED, WHICH IS WHAT THIS
FRANCHISE DID.
IT RUNS AFOUL OF THE ORIGINAL
VISION AND THE MOVIE, WHICH WAS
BEAUTIFUL WOMEN WHO COULD DEFEND
THEMSELVES.
BUT THEY WERE PART OF A TEAM BUT
THEY USED THEIR BEAUTY AND WILES
TO GET THEIR WAY.
NOT ONLY THROWING 300-POUND MET
THROUGH PLATE GLASS WINDOW.
>> Laura: SHOULD I REVEAL TO THE
AUDIENCE THAT WE HAVE OUR OWN
LAURA INGRAHAM ANGELS.
>> HELLO, ANGELS.
>> IT'S FUN.
>> IT'S TOMMY.
I'M BOSLEY.
>> Laura: YEAH.
TOMMY IS LIKE DON'T SAY ANYTHING
ABOUT THAT.
IT'S THE P.C. THING, JUST RUINED
CINEMA.
IT RUINS IT.
>> RUINED THE NEW "TERMINATOR"